[Música]
pues fue un caracara imperdible así fue
ese último debate presidencial
televisado en francia entre el
presidente y aspirante a la reelección
emanuel macon de la república en marcha
y marine lepén de agrupación nacional un
debate en el que ambos candidatos
hablaron sobre ocho ejes temáticos que
abarcaron temas como el poder
adquisitivo de los franceses la
diplomacia el sistema de pensiones la
competitividad del país educación las
juventudes medioambiente y gobernanza
solamente por mencionarles algunos 5
años han tenido que pasar para que macro
y lepén vuelvan a enfrentarse en una
mesa de debate que sirvió entre muchos
aspectos para convencer a los votantes
indecisos ya esos votantes de los
candidatos que se quedaron en la primera
vuelta presidencial todo en un momento
cuando las encuestas están mostrando una
intención de voto muy reñida de cara a
esos comicios del 24 de abril en donde
francia se juega el todo por el todo
el análisis del último cara a cara entre
manuel macro y marine lepén es nuestro
tema de debate de análisis aquí en el
debate de france 24 en directo américa
emisión nocturna bienvenidos soy
santiago lópez gonzález y para analizar
este tema hemos invitado entonces a
maría josé zorrilla ella es analista
política y máster en cooperación y
desarrollo internacional se encuentra en
la ciudad de lima la capital de perú y
desde parís en francia se conecta a esta
conversación pascal él es analista
político y especialista en relaciones
internacionales ustedes por supuesto
también hacen parte de este debate con
todos sus comentarios y sus preguntas
les recuerdo que estamos en todas las
redes sociales en facebook en instagram
y en twitter estamos como france24 bajo
ese santi logo que es mi cuenta personal
les recuerdo que nuestra etiqueta es
numeral el debate efe 24 esperamos todos
sus comentarios y sus preguntas comienzo
entonces por darle la bienvenida a
nuestra primera invitada maría josé que
la presentaba en la ciudad de lima en
perú
maria jose buenas noches bienvenida y
quiero conocer como punto de partida
para el debate las impresiones generales
que le deja esta confrontación este cara
a cara de lo que vimos y los puntos para
destacar antes de entrar en materia y en
el análisis de los en tres puntos
muchas gracias santiago por la
invitación y sí claro realmente ha sido
un debate bastante pasión ante muy
diferente al debate del 2017 y podemos
ver que por el lado de marie le pen ha
habido una cierta una cierta ligereza en
el mal momento de responder los ataques
después se mandaron a chrome sobre todo
se hablaban bastante diferentes temas
como el poder el poder de compra la
ecología la
europa etc sobre todo cuál sería el rol
de estancia dentro de una europea y creo
que a mí me ha dejado una sensación de
en donde ambos candidatos no no siento
que haya habido un
un vencedor en este debate dentro que
ambos candidatos han mejorado con
respecto a las últimas elecciones pero
siento que todavía tiene algunos puntos
que mejorar puntos para mejorar son
parte de las reflexiones que hace maría
josé zorrilla desde la ciudad de lima
vamos a ver qué nos dice pascal desde la
ciudad de parís en francia su opinión
impresiones generales de este debate
sobre el manejo que vimos por parte de
los candidatos y también algunos de los
puntos que usted quiera destacar antes
de entrar en materia pascal bienvenido
muchas gracias santiago un gusto pues
para mí me pareció obvio que hizo
pusieron dos visiones claramente y los
candidatos convinieron de esas
diferencias importantes una visión del
candidato presidente en el marco
que pone la independencia europea con
una francia fuerte es decir una francia
que puede contestar a los desafíos
la palanca europea y al lado de la unión
europea y otra visión con una voluntad
de promover la soberanía una soberanía
nacional la de imagen ep pero con
bastante contradicciones y lo vimos muy
bien en todos los temas árabes
económicos pero por supuesto
los temas relacionados a europa entonces
dos visiones diferentes una que se puede
referir un poco y lo hizo y manuel macro
a una visión
universalista y otra que consiste en una
visión más nacionalista de soberanía
nacional dos visiones distintas
importantes de conclusión para destacar
por parte de nuestro invitado maria jose
quiero que analicemos el papel de mar
independent este en este debate
televisado se le vio muy distinta a ese
debate del 2017 ya usted lo mencionaba
que recoge usted de el desempeño de ella
de la forma en que expresó sus ideas
confrontó a macro ni en el debate
claro yo creo que recordemos que marie
le pen es obviamente hija de jean-marie
le pen entonces tiene toda esa carga
histórica familiar y también ha tenido
estos cinco años del 2017 para
prepararse realmente se le ha visto como
una candidata bastante sólida y
preparada ha sabido
expresar y transmitir sus ideas de
manera clara y sobre todo me parece que
a diferencia de manual macro es claro
que es bastante se critica macrón que no
tiene que tener un aire como de profesor
de de hablar al ser cantitos me parece
que marín lepe
realmente ha llegado a su electorado y
eso me parece positivo pero por otro
lado siento que ha fallado un poco en
justamente el objetivo del debate que es
convencer a los indecisos convencer a
ese 20 por ciento que votó son mejor son
maría josé a quien le estaba apuntando
la pena convencer a que el sector de la
sociedad francesa está en juego desde su
lado político desde el espectro político
que ya representa a quienes puede
conquistar en esta noche de bateo a
quienes pudo conquistar
claro según la encuesta de ipsos
hasta el momento hay solamente el 12 por
ciento de franceses quienes están
indecisos por su voto entonces sería
justamente a este 12% entre los cuales
por ejemplo están los jóvenes y podría
hablar de temas como por ejemplo en la
educación en la universidad también pues
de cierta manera
en cierto sector de los migrantes y
sobre todo a los franceses de las
regiones de france a quienes en la
gestión de macrón de por por la cob iría
ahora recientemente por lo de la guerra
podría podría estarle chocando
paso a preguntarle a pascal por sus
impresiones que tenga sobre la candidata
lp en ese público al que quería
convencer y le abro la pregunta también
hacia el presidente y candidato ma con
sus impresiones sobre el desempeño que
tuvo sí pero como bien dijo maria jose
el debate de 2022 fue diferente de el
que tuvimos en 2017 así cinco años
definitivamente
en el trabajo trabajo la forma había
sido desastroso el debate de 2017 así
que se centró en los temas que abordaron
de manera amplia que sean temas
económicos sociales como dijimos tanto
de juventud a nivel internacional
etcétera
realmente el emmanuel mccall
se notaba pues una
un conocimiento profundo de los temas y
ahí fue creo una falla para marín de
penn es decir que al contrario del año
de
2017 cuando los dos candidatos de hoy
fueron también candidatos de la segunda
vuelta a diferencia de 2017 ma jin open
fue menos ofensiva ponemos y pareció
sobre temas económicos cuando
emanuel marco pudo revelar unas
contradicciones pareció según mi juicio
yo la vi bastante apagada y eso fue
sorprendente por supuesto sobre los
temas tradicionales de la agrupación
nacional el partido de imagen lotes en
los temas de inmigración
dentro de otros ahí aparecía más firme
pero realmente en los temas económicos y
sobre todo los temas de cómo van a
financiar el sus programas el programa
sobre las jubilaciones el programa sobre
la energía verde como si financiará me
pareció bastante importa lo que sí es
cierto y ya lo dicen muchos analistas es
que este debate y ustedes incluso ya lo
están aquí mencionando tuvo mucho más
altura si bien hubo señalamientos entre
los candidatos no fue esa guerra de
señalamientos que hubo en el 2017 que un
poco más de altura en cuanto a la forma
en que ellos se escucharon e
intercambiaron ideas y se confrontaron
quiero entonces entrar a la agenda de
los temas que trataron estos ocho ejes
no los vamos a poder abarcar todos por
cuestiones de tiempo vamos a sacar los
más destacados comenzamos con el tema
del poder adquisitivo tenemos palabras
de los dos candidatos comienzo
presentándoles en algunas de los
extractos de lo que dijo la candidata
lepén y luego vemos los del candidato
macro para comenzar el análisis
y yo quiero que el poder adquisitivo sea
la prioridad de mi mandato si los
franceses confían en mí
mediante tres medidas bajar los
impuestos quiero bajar de manera perenne
no con tiquetes de racionamiento no con
cosas temporales sino de manera siempre
la el impuesto sobre las ventas sobre la
energía de 20 a 5.5 por ciento porque
pienso que la energía es un bien de
primera necesidad
bueno en resumen bajar impuestos es lo
que dice la cantidad del epen pascal su
opinión sobre estas propuestas que hace
la candidata
pues ahí sobre ese tema por cierto es un
tema muy de actualidad
relacionado por supuesto a las
consecuencias económicas de la guerra
porque no olvidemos que europa hoy en
día vive una guerra ahí se confrontó
otra vez dos visiones la visión de
manuel maicon que consiste en establecer
un escudo en congelar precios sobre
precios sobre el gas sobre la
electricidad
para poder contestar ya a ese tema del
poder adquisito entendiendo pues que
todos queremos que poder éxito de todos
sea mejor y sea por supuesto el más alto
ahora imagine el pp propone una baja de
impuestos de pelea de 20 a 5 por ciento
sobre
esos productos
que participan de la vida ciudad de la
vida cotidiana de los ciudadanos es por
eso que llegó que eso lo quería
establecer de manera perenne pero vemos
y sabemos perfectamente que eso no va a
finalmente a mejorar el poder anticipo
del ciudadano porque ahí allí por
supuesto esto no va a corregir de tal
manera la invitación no va a corregir
una alta que puede haber de precios
sobre otros productos entonces ahí si
esas dos visiones el escudo y por otra
parte la baja de la idea de impuestos
pues revelaron esas dos visiones
diferentes dos caras distintas maria
jose a su opinión
y si concuerdo completamente con pascal
evidentemente hay dos visiones de una
francia y de una economía francesa
completamente diferentes y me parece que
la adoro en la intervención de
justamente ella resalta esto de los
monos o de los tickets porque fue una de
las medidas que el gobierno de francia
tomó durante la cuarentena durante el
periodo de kobe y claro hay un malestar
hay un malestar bastante
creciente dentro de la población de la
clase media y también de las clases
populares a distancia y creo que
justamente lo que ambos candidatos
quieren ganar es justamente están
buscando este electorado si según las
encuestas este tema es el tema prioridad
de los franceses por encima de la guerra
por encima del cob y por encima de otros
temas económicos el poder adquisitivo es
tal vez lo que más les ha afectado su
bolsillo escuchemos las palabras del
candidato y presidente también el
aspirante a la reelección de manuel
marco y finalizamos este punto
entonces lo que nosotros hicimos y lo
que yo asumo y lo que quiero mantener
ahora es ante los precios de la energía
como lo dijo el señor en un escudo que
significa bloquear los precios la
electricidad y el gas y eso es dos veces
más eficaz que reducir el iva y me
permito decir que los franceses las
francesas tendrán un aumento de sus
facturas de algunas decenas o incluso
cientos de euros si ustedes la eligen
porque usted votó en contra de este
escudo energético bueno confrontación
allí maríajosé puntos encontrados que
ustedes ya explicaban el balance cuál de
estas propuestas puede ser más viable
dada la coyuntura que está presentando
francia en este momento
pues yo creo que
ambos candidatos bien por supuesto
tienen
propuestas bastante viables y bastante
bastante coherentes pero bueno creo que
igual depende del sector a labor de las
colas a las que van a ir
dirigir me parece me parece resaltable
ciertas propuestas de macro como por
ejemplo la que acaba de mencionar por
ejemplo también las de marín dependen en
reducir ciertos ciertos impuestos sobre
todo para la clase trabajadora porque
realmente como estábamos comentando hay
un gran descontento en esta clase en
esta clase social en francia y
justamente esto se ha traducido en por
ejemplo hace dos años en los chalecos
amarillos y esto la crisis también del
gas y el petróleo no eres
pascal si tiene algo para terminar y
redondear en este tema sobre la
propuesta de macrón le doy la palabra si
no pasamos al tema de diplomacia
pues definitivamente es realmente para
él
una prioridad es seguir por la
disminución de los impuestos sobre la
producción y seguir también con la
capacitación la formación de un millón
de personas a todos los nuevos empleos
de transición numérica todo eso te
contribuye a
a ese contexto de dinamizar
el
ambiente económico y de empleo que
obviamente participa de ese tema
económico en un contexto como bien
tiempo maria jose de definitamente de un
malestar y en eso todos coincidimos
estos cinco últimos años han sido años
complicados dos años y medio de pandemia
y vida y hablaremos seguramente de la
deuda comida de explicación de lo que
significa pero tuvimos la crisis de los
de las camisas amarillas es decir que
hubo un contexto socioeconómico bastante
duro a raíz de la pandemia como lo dijo
de manuel ma con una una recesión tres
veces más fuerte que la de 2008 de la
crisis financiera que vivió el mundo es
decir el nivel de las metas
a nivel de los desafíos y tuvieron que
levantar
durante esos 12 años la vamos a
profundizar en el tema de economía que
también está ligado al tema del consumo
y del poder adquisitivo de los franceses
quiero pasar a él que es tal vez el
punto álgido de este debate así lo
decíamos en el bloque informativo aquí
en directo américa edición nocturna y
fue esa confrontación por el tema de
rusia la relación o cercanía que puede
tener en marín de pn con el presidente
ruso vladimir putin
marcó claramente posiciones muy marcadas
en cuanto a la escena internacional
escuchemos lo que dijo marín le pen
sobre estas acusaciones
la única sanción con la cual yo no
estuve de acuerdo es el bloqueo de la
importación del gas y el petróleo rusos
porque porque pienso que ese no es el
mejor método pienso que eso no le hará
ningún daño a rusia y sobre todo si le
va a hacer mucho mal al pueblo francés y
pienso que las consecuencias de ese
bloqueo nos han anunciado que sería
negociado por la unión europea después
de la elección presidencial francesa
pienso entonces que este bloqueo tendría
consecuencias cataclísmicas no solamente
sobre los particulares sino también para
las empresas
también fue señalada por el presidente y
candidato macro por ese préstamo que
tuvo el partido de marie le pen a un
banco checo ruso para poder financiar
parte de su campaña en las elecciones
anteriores el presidente y actual
candidato manuel macrón se refirió a
este otros temas escuchemos
usted depende del poder no sé usted
depende del señor putin porque después
de unos meses de haber dicho eso usted
tomó un préstamo en 2015 ante un banco
ruso la franquet russian bank
en septiembre de 2014 y después
eso está desconocido y conocido
notariado
y están implicados en la guerra en síria
entonces usted no está hablando a otros
dirigentes ustedes está hablando a su
banquero cuando habla de rusia y ese es
el problema señor depende
maria jose en términos de estrategia
política este tema está esta
confrontación estos reclamos por parte
de macrón al epen que tanto tiene
estrategia de debate y que tanto de
verdad es un tema relevante esa relación
que pueda tener lepén para esta campaña
para lo que le resta en estos días de
campaña para las elecciones del domingo
claro definitivamente la relación
cercana entre el empeño útil puede tomar
la manera negativa por los votantes pero
de nuevo otros regresamos de nuevo a
esto de las diferentes visiones la paro
marie le pen quiere una francia soberana
una francia que justamente
por eso justamente
y señaló que estaba en contra del
bloqueo de gas pero por otro lado macro
él también depende de la unión europea y
obviamente quiere que francia él desde
una visión más como bueno claro pero
europeizante europeizada entonces él
quiere que francia sea a la cabeza la
unión europea y por lo tanto yo creo que
en este momento no hay tanto no hay
tantos y buenos malos negativos
positivos solamente es un juego de
intereses que están por detrás detrás de
los candidatos también recordemos que el
premio es justamente el primer día de la
intervención de rusia ucrania el único
presidente con el conversó por teléfono
o por teléfono fue en valor macro eso es
muy diciente se ha reunido o ha
conversado con él por teléfono varias
veces para tratar de mitigar un poco la
situación en ucrania pascal es su
opinión sobre este tema y lo traemos a
colación porque la coyuntura
internacional así lo pide la situación a
nivel internacional y la presión
internacional sobre rusia por
guerra en ucrania es muy grande y esto
le puede pasar factura a los candidatos
si no lo manejan estratégicamente a
nivel político como lo ve usted si pues
santiago primero recordamos que emanuel
marcó
hasta
el final del mes de junio es a la vez el
presidente del consejo europeo es decir
que preside para esos seis primeros
meses del año la unión europea primero
tiene esta responsabilidad
segundo como bien dijo europa vive
conoce una guerra en su tierra y esa
guerra
provocada por rusia ya está cambiando el
mundo
eso es la situación estamos entrando en
un mundo nuevo en la búsqueda de un
nuevo
equilibrio mundial de un nuevo sistema
de seguridad
europea y de seguridad mundial vemos
pues el nuevo papel de reserva de
prudencia que tiene china china que es
un socio económico esencial hoy en día
por ejemplo en américa latina estamos
viendo pues que la unión europea y es
decir europa tiene que volver y es lo
que llamaron los países miembros los 27
a una potencia europea eso visto desde
europa y en este caso viéndolo yo desde
parís es algo histórico es una visión
que nunca tuvieron los europeos desde el
tratado de roma de 1957 que quiero decir
te quiero decir que estamos viviendo ya
desde el mes de febrero desde el
principio
la guerra en ucrania estamos viviendo
tiempos nuevos que necesitan exigen una
búsqueda de independencia de autonomía
europea y eso autonomía energética
autonomía en materia de defensa de
inteligencia etcétera es un ángulo que
tiene muy claro y ahí apareció en el
marco y por qué militarmente depende de
la alianza atlántica de eeuu y
energéticamente de rusia y otros países
del medio oriente pasó al tema económico
para tocarlo rápidamente aquí pues por
supuesto hubo
propuestas encontradas lepén no sé si
ustedes están de acuerdo se mostró como
como una ciudadana de clase media
defensora de los obreros
víctima de la arrogancia de este mandato
de cinco años del presidente macro en
cuanto a sus políticas económicas pero
macro no le apostó a que el país tiene
que seguir trabajando retrasar un poco
la jubilación destacó que a lo largo de
su gobierno ha habido una reducción en
cuanto al desempleo aunque las cifras
por la crisis de la pandemia de kobe 19
pues le juegan en contra todos los
gobiernos debido a la situación que se
presentó maria jose impresiones del tema
económico
y claro creo que esto ha sido uno de los
temas que más ha causado polémica al
menos en la primera vuelta el tema de
las pensiones
marcaron tiene que justamente las
personas se puedan mayores puedan estar
retiro a los 65 años mientras que marín
le plantea que se pueda pasar la panza
la pensión entre 70 a 62 años y
realmente claro para nosotros pueden o
no puede significar una mayor un mayor
cambio tres cuatro o cinco años pero
esto puede impactar de manera realmente
será la economía y bueno de nuevo son
dos visiones de economía dos visiones de
las francés completamente diferentes
y pascal su opinión el tema económico el
tema de pensiones ustedes de conocerlo
muy bien allí en su país es todo un
debate a nivel nacional
si lo es definitivamente y es un debate
extremadamente importante sensible que
explica pues también
que lleva sobre temas de unidad social
el tema llega sobre temas del
endeudamiento pues ahí como dijo maria
jose dos visiones en francia tenemos un
sistema de pensiones por
repartición
es decir que a diferencia de otros
países en el continente americano
ponemos que puede ser un sistema por
capitalización aquí los activos preparan
para los que están jubilados y por
cierto pues el sistema debe evolucionar
porque porque hoy se vive mucho más
viejo gracias a dios pero todo eso tiene
un costo entonces el mayor el marco
propuso
hasta
2031 que se pueda trabajar obviamente
más pero serían cuatro meses al año
gradualmente para llegar en
2031 a
60 a la edad de 65 años para poder a
tasa plena irse a jubilación mientras
imagine lo ven sin explicar cómo se va a
financiar
propone una salida de la jubilación de
los 60 hasta los 62 años
sin explicar cómo se puede financiar
entonces hay sonidos otra vez
percepciones visiones y del enlace
también al trabajo a la peni bilidad del
trabajo lo que subrayó por cierto el
candidato macro que es un tema también
que entra en el cálculo de la jubilación
la inhibida del trabajo tantos temas
agregados a ese tema de jubilación bueno
ya pasamos un poco más allá de la mitad
del programa voy a unir dos temas que
tenía por separado y es el tema de las
relaciones internacionales el
posicionamiento de francia y el tema de
la unión europea que claramente genera
controversia entre los dos candidatos en
lepe habla de una reforma urgente a la
unión europea ya la otan
macro no habla de mantener la doble
soberanía es decir la soberanía francesa
y la europea y hay percepciones muy
distintas en torno al papel de francia
en el bloque de los 27 escuchemos qué
fue lo que propuso la candidata marín de
penn
lo que deseo es que la comisión europea
respete a las naciones soberanas y
respete sus decisiones incluso sus
decisiones de sociedad porque son
decisiones de sociedad lo que hacemos
cuando votamos los franceses y yo
considero que la comisión europea debe
respetarlos lo que yo quiero es que esta
organización evolucione esta
organización europea pero señor marco no
pensé que usted iba a caer en una
especie de conspiración mismo yo no
quiero salir de la unión europeo
si yo quisiera salir lo diría si digo
que no quiero salir de la unión europeo
no lo dijo ella dice que no quiere salir
pero los analistas dicen que es su
proyecto político así lo dice entre
líneas da para el debate del análisis
pero escuchamos lo que dice el candidato
macro
su proyecto cuando lo ponemos
ladrillo a ladrillo las cosas es un
proyecto que no dice su nombre pero que
quiere hacernos salir de europa
pero si se quiere salir de la unión
europea pues sale de la unión europea
señora repente podemos querer pintar la
fachada pero en algún momento en una
copropiedad usted no puede decir
simplemente ya no es una copropiedad se
llama como yo he decidido porque yo me
llamo señor depende lo confronta a uno
de los presidentes más pro europeos tal
vez además que está a la cabeza del
consejo europeo maria jose adelante su
opinión
bueno pues yo creo que hay una
contradicción en el discurso de marinero
porque por supuesto en 2017 ha repetido
varias veces que justamente quería
cambiar el euro por el tranco que la
antigua moneda en francia y también pues
siempre no lo ha señalado directamente
pero siempre ha tenido como propuestas
bastante
esto
bueno para salir justamente en europea
pero por otro lado claro reveló también
un agrupamiento nacional y en el
parlament a los europeos que los cuales
brega justamente por una
por la defensa de los derechos por la
defensa de los intereses de los
intereses del pueblo francés entonces no
me parece bien sinceramente yo no creo
que marine quiera atacar a francia de la
europea porque clase tiene un rol líder
dentro de europeo y ahora de el consejo
pero creo que si quiere proteger los
intereses que ella considera
ella aboga por el cierre absoluto de las
fronteras francesas y proteger la
industria nacional industria local
pascal su opinión
pues primero está retomando el discurso
clásico del extrema derecha en fracc
a es decir queremos una en este caso hoy
en día dice alianza europea de las
naciones es una denuncia sin decirlo del
sistema de unidad en la diversidad
europea en la cual se construyó ese
sistema europeo desde el final de los
años 50 se creó el primer
mercado comercial del mundo en la unión
europea y se ha creado una prosperidad
la voluntad de la construcción europea a
partir de
1957 el primer tratado de roma al cual
participó obviamente alemania francia y
estaban los seis primeros países en qué
consistía consistía nunca más nunca más
la guerra se paseó ropa se unió en el
siglo 20 en dos guerras mundiales que
acaba
con los países europeos entonces se tuvo
que reconstruir un sistema que permitía
consagrar una forma de estabilidad y de
prosperidad pero obviamente en eso se
debe compartir
hoy en día el espacio cuenta con 27
países y obviamente lo que dice marín
epen no consiguió pues una postura que
permita garantizar la unidad europea en
la diversidad de los países miembros que
todos deben comprar bien además la
dificultad hoy en día y acabó con eso
pero la dificultad para
lo que dice ma jin noten es que rota
vive la guerra está traduciendo una
guerra una guerra que está cambiando
todo el equilibrio mundial y el
particularmente la posición de la unión
europea entonces ahí cómo hacer que ir
yendo por reforzar las fronteras
nacionales en ipiales miembro de una
unidad y a la vez contar en un espacio
confrontado a la guerra me quedan pocos
minutos para finalizar el programa creo
que voy a terminar con uno de los temas
de controversia a nivel cultural y
social en francia y es esa propuesta en
cuanto al tema de migración y en cuanto
al uso del velo islámico esto fue lo que
dijo marie le pen en torno a este tema
pienso que la gran mayoría de las
mujeres jóvenes que usan yo no pueden
hacerlo de otra manera aunque no se
aprueban a decirlo porque a las que no
lo usas dicen que eso la s terminan
siendo aisladas insultadas
[Música]
marginadas muy acusadas de ser impuras
esta situación no es admisible en
nuestro país por eso hay que liberar a
todas estas mujeres hay que hacer que
los islamistas retrocedan y creo que
para eso hay que prohibir el uso del
velo en el espacio público
el presidente manuel macro en también
aspirante a la reelección indicó que él
no lucha contra el islam él lucha contra
el extremismo islámico que son dos
conceptos muy diferentes esto fue lo que
le respondió a la candidata le pena
las leyes que usted pretende establecer
si es elegida qué es lo que yo no deseo
tendrán que respetar una constitución
entonces nuestra constitución nuestros
textos fundamentales dicen eso es el
laicismo el laicismo es un principio de
libertad entonces en la escuela 9 no
porque estamos formando conciencias no
hay ningún signo religioso no es
solamente el velo islámico- todos las
formas de signos religiosos no están
permitidas porque estamos formando
conciencias de los futuros ciudadanos en
los servicios públicos también hay
neutralidad pero en la ciudad
usted va a crear una guerra civil se lo
digo con toda sinceridad
una guerra civil así lo calificó el
presidente cantidad toma crohn hablamos
de libertades de laicismo de derechos
humanos maria jose a impresiones en este
punto para el cierre
yo considero que ambos candidatos están
perfectamente apuntando al tiempo cierto
sector musulmán del electorado
obviamente ambos quieren
atraer a este electorado que yo creo que
la mayoría ha votado por el alumno tiene
la visión porque claro me la acción está
con una de sus pasiones es encuentran en
marsella entonces yo creo que es ambas
propuestas son justamente
busca atraer este cierto punto pero
bueno igual imagino que ya más adelante
lo van a decir pero el debate sobre el
velo es un debate bastante bastante
antiguo es francia y parece que siempre
resurge con cada polémica con cada
elección presidencial y bueno creo que
es un tema que todavía va a continuar
claro no tiene ningún tipo de solución
siempre está sobre la mesa lo conversan
lo debaten pero no tienen una solución o
un fin de discusión para sacar su
opinión
pues si tiene una solución la solución
se llama la laicidad de respeto de las
reglas de la república fue lo que
reafirmó el candidato macro en qué
consiste consiste en el respeto de cada
quien en los espacios públicos
llevando nadie ningún signos y ostenta
territorios de religión pues se está
construyendo una conciencia de vivir
juntos y eso es el tema hoy en día en
francia es como reconstruir un sentido
de interés común una comunidad nacional
que no sea reemplazada por una forma de
comunitarismo eso es esencial en francia
porque la república francesa está basada
y esos son principios constitucionales
está basada sobre ese principio de
mismos derechos mismos deberes
todos los ciudadanos en una comunidad
nacional y la laicidad es que ha sido
que nació en 1905 así es fundan el más
fundamental el pilar de estos principios
pascal y maria jose les agradezco mucho
por este análisis es sobre este tema se
nos acaba el tiempo se nos quedan
algunos temas del debate por fuera del
análisis pero les agradezco haber estado
con nosotros y ustedes pueden seguir con
nuestra programación sigan con nosotros
gracias
[Música]